lamar jackson he will be the nfl's mvp
that award gets handed out in a few
weeks the night before the super bowl he
was incredible it was amazing to see him
revolutionize the position
the same way that patrick mahomes did
just last year in a different way
totally different way 1200 plus yards
rushing to change the league with 36
touchdown passes yeah so many of those
highlights where he causes a guy to fall
down
uh incredible and uh last year was not
incredible against the chargers in the
first half of the eventual loss in the
wild card round two of eight passing for
17 yards and an interception that was a
home game too it was for the ravens who
had won the division last year in the
fourth quarter he woke it up but it was
too little too late
and it seems that he understands the
importance of coming out of the gates
hot and look i i think that
last year's loss has little relevance
this time around i agree because the
team is so much better the team is so
much different he's so much better he's
so much different than he was last year
yeah that i think i think that it's not
a situation where like it's going to
become your narrative if you keep losing
playoff games i was concerned for desean
watson that would be the case sure i'm
not concerned even if they lose i'm not
concerned this is going to stick to
lamar jackson well i just yeah first off
i'm with you mike i don't think the
chargers game has any bearing on this
year the baltimore ravens are so much
better they have more offense this year
they know how to answer some of the
things that the chargers did to them uh
and and the big thing too other than
that is i just think they're better
equipped than what they were last year
one lamar jackson just he's a better
thrower of the football this year
there's no denying that i mean even this
year he got better and better as the
year went so if you're going to be crazy
and just get up in the line of scrimmage
and go oh we're going to put nine and 10
guys up there to stop lamar jackson
go ahead but like he's gonna beat you
deep with mark andrews or hollywood
brown he's gonna that's he's proven that
so that question is out the door that's
gone he can beat you with his right arm
plus all the three tight end sets you
know having a mark andrew and hayden
hurst and boyle those three guys you
know uh so effective put defenses in a
bind that way too to where you go oh
gosh we got to get big and stop this
power run game but then all three of
those tight ends can kind of all split
out and be a part of the pass game so
they put you in a bind there and he is
accurate and he takes care of the
football he does everything that right
way this baltimore team is just they're
better than last year their defense is
better he's better the offense is better
and i don't know do you feel like
there's a team in the league this year
that has more like team unity than the
baltimore ravens too they're they're
right they're the teams they seem like
everything right it does seem that way i
agree there's all and now the thing
doesn't always mean 49ers and the ravens
have that both they both but only one of
them can win it yeah maybe neither of
them will we'll see but you're right the
ravens all year long have been that team
that kind of captures our imagination
yeah the great sound bites from mark
ingram after games when we started to
realize lamar jackson is the mvp not
patrick mahomes not anyone else right
and and i think that that has really
added to that flavor that the ravens
bring to the table one of the challenges
that any team that faces the ravens will
confront who simulates lamar jackson in
practice right and maybe the titans have
the best one we've talked about one of
them in the week marcus mariota yeah
still on the team not the starter but in
position where his contributions during
practice could help the titans defense
be better equipped to slow down lamar
jackson because i mean we've talked
about it in the past with other
quarterbacks like you can do what you
want to try to simulate a guy but good
luck actually stopping that guy because
no one on your team is as good as that
guy yeah well yeah we see it every week
where we just go okay yeah the defense
was in great position they scattered it
out perfect they knew what to do oh yeah
you're one-on-one with lamar jackson no
he's running by you right now and now
you're five yards behind him because
you're just not ready for the talent and
the explosion you see i mean yes marcus
mariota is probably as close as you're
gonna get one of the heisman backups in
this football game as far as the
quarterbacks are concerned but even with
marcus mariota he's not lamar jackson
lamar jackson's acceleration is next
level he could go zero to 60 in three
steps and i think the other thing that
makes him you know and i think you feel
this way too that makes him special or
more special than any quarterback we've
ever seen him run and michael vick was
the one i saw in person where i went oh
my gosh he doesn't have a rocket up his
butt he doesn't have two of them he's
got three of them i don't know if lamar
is straight ahead as fast as michael
vick but he's got more wiggle and that's
where i think he's amazing i mean in the
open field have we seen anybody really
tackle him one-on-one all year i feel
like he always makes the first guy miss
and then you got to kind of rally there
as a team to make him make him slow him
down and one thing that i think he has
learned as the season has progressed and
i think the leg injury he suffered
against the bills helped him come to
this conclusion on his own you know
because sometimes and i remember when i
was a kid and i was reaching toward that
little metal pilot light at the top of
the stove my mom was saying you're gonna
burn your finger you're gonna burn your
finger and i still did it i had to burn
my finger to realize it right lamar
jackson had to take that big hit and
realize oh wait a minute there is value
in getting out of bounds in sliding
we've seen that very very subtly we have
seen it take root later in the season
that serves him well also it reduces the
chance he's going to get injured once he
does break free and and get his yards
instead of trying to get an extra five
or ten he just takes it gets down that's
right he doesn't need to the the extra
four or five yards they're a machine
right now and i would be shocked if we
don't see the machine keep rolling
against the tennessee titans tennessee
titans hey they're well coached they got
something enjoyed in the game and
shorten the game yeah keep lamar jackson
off the field i think that's the key
weather the storm 128 to 31 the ravens
of outscored teams in the first quarter
yeah that's that's whether the storm
earth that just shows you they jump out
now you with their talent their
aggression and intensity all of those
things we'll see if they can weather
that storm
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports